[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the galaxy note 2 or iphone 5
giveaway let's go so in my last video we
took an in-depth look and review of the
galaxy note 2 and basically deemed that
it's one of the best smartphones around
and as you guys may already know john
from tld today in one of his more recent
videos he also reviewed the iphone 5 and
he also deemed it one of the best
smartphones available so now the choice
is all on you the choice is yours so
this is a collaborative giveaway with
john from tld today so all you need to
do to win is to be subscribed to both of
our channels and to leave a comment
which one of these super phones you
would want it's that simple one lucky
winner will get his or her comment wish
to come true iphone 5 or galaxy note 2.
that rhymed commenting on this video
below is one entry that gets your name
into the pool if you want to double your
chances of winning there is a video on
the tld today channel where you can
leave a comment and that will also get
you an entry one comment per video and
you have two entries to win a galaxy
note 2 or an iphone 5. and just for you
guys right below the thumbs up button on
this video there is a link to my galaxy
note 2 review and a link to john's
iphone 5 review so you know exactly what
you're getting yourself into before you
pick if you don't want to pick right now
and winner also gets to choose the color
so if you pick an iphone black or white
and if you pick a galaxy note 2 you get
to pick white or marble gray and this is
an international giveaway so anyone can
win this unlocked device and if you
happen to be in a country where the
unlocked device an iphone 5 or a note 2
won't float your boat we can settle for
a cash equivalent for the winner and
that winner will be announced in exactly
two weeks from today on october 30th on
twitter so the twitter links will be
below you're going to want to stay tuned
to those probably want to follow those
to be first to be updated on these
giveaways and to know if you won your
pick so either way that's basically it
best of luck for you guys who are
commenting again remember to comment on
both and be subscribed to both channels
and if you haven't already checked out
tld today's videos they're really good
so if you haven't already subscribed to
him go do that and check out the rest of
his videos too i watch them all the time
either way thanks for watching best of
luck in winning your pick of an iphone 5
or a galaxy note 2 probably two of the
best smartphones out there today i'll
talk to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
you